what up space fam goes in here from
anime op crore and today we're going to
be talking about the latest crazy
developments in the one piece story the
last few chapters were great with Jim
BAE's return and whatnot but things are
really getting on their way now huge
stuff revealed so make sure to stay
tuned for that if you enjoy seeing these
one piece reviews and want to keep them
coming show one piece some love by
smashing that like button and sharing
this video if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell or you will miss
future one piece videos if you want
early access to our reviews including
one piece follow enemy up or audio on
Spotify Apple podcasts or wherever else
you listen to podcasts links in the
description keep in mind there will be
manga spoilers in this video we are
talking about the latest chapter chapter
977 apps are all now without further ado
let's jump into it this chapter is
called the party won't start now
remember last chapter Jim Bay showed up
in wow it was an extremely epic
reintroduction he completely and
effortlessly devastated the huge ship
that was giving our boys trouble the
straw hats are excited to have Jim Bay
back of course and so a welcome party
would be an order but as the title
suggests it's probably not the best time
for a party right now the chapter starts
off with our guys gleeful screaming out
for Jim Bay we are told that the 10th
straw hats are finally together and it
feels amazing Luffy reveals that Jim Bay
had them worried and Jim Bay apologizes
for being late explaining that he
carried the wounded son pirates and also
had a goodbye party it's so fun seeing
how all these characters react with
their different personalities they're
all happy to see Jen Bay but show it in
a different way
for instance Zorro smiles while Luffy
Nami chopper and carrot Ron just going
for the hug while you saw Frankie and
Brooke cheer Sanjay appears jealous that
Karen and Nami are hugging Jim Bay and
not him Robin is more stoic like Zorro
everyone has their own personality and
it shows in little moments like this
again one of the things I love about Oda
even Jim Bay's face is great you can see
how happy he is to be part of this
nakooma and although it may be Cory to
say it's truly a touching panel that
captures the beauty of friendship
perfectly Jim Bay the strong former
warlord completely revitalizes the crew
and brings up the morale through the
roof after Luffy himself Jim Bay has the
biggest bounty after
at 438 million berries he gives them
significantly more muscle power in the
fight ahead Nami tells Frankie that Jim
Bay is an incredible helmsman Frankie
wonders if he can bring the best out of
his dream ship and chopper assures him
by saying that Jim Bay was surfing with
the sunny
Frankie is on board and at this point
everyone wants to drink to celebrate Jim
Bay's return they don't actually have
alcohol but Zorro can feel it if we know
two things about Zorro is that he sucks
with directions and he loves his booze
he loves it so much that he can sense
its presence that must be some
customized observation haki at work
right there as this reunions going on
Tina moon tries to make sure Luffy knows
the plan while law is just like bro you
can't strategize with Luffy as we saw
when he just wanted to move full speed
straight ahead at the enemy ship last
chapter Luffy doesn't usually think
about problems he just rammed through
them which is entertaining but it can
also lead to impulsive premature attacks
like when he got destroyed by Kaito
earlier on in the arc that's why I'm
glad we have a balance with more
strategizing characters right now like
law and Keenan one Sicilian the captain
of the in washi musketeer shows up
wanting to listen to the plan he
promises to serve as a vassal for the
Kisuke clan during this war law
commanding the Minx we get a nice moment
we're in watashi tells his protege that
he's counting on him Yakuza gram Co Goro
offers to lead the samurais so that
everyone can focus on their own fights
we get a bit of juicy info about the
island upon a Kashima its geography
which is actually fascinating it's like
the perfect fortress it's lined with
mountains so that the only way to get in
should be through the main entrance
there's a large skull mountain with the
castle in it
there's also a secret passage at the
back of it the idea was that once they
get through the entrance of the island
to split into two groups and to make
their way to the secret passage behind
skull mountain they're gonna attack
title while he's drunk
then Jura being a man of reason points
out that that's the plain Cointreau the
traitor knows but what's the real one
again King Timon is shocked he didn't
account for having to change the plan at
all since he never actually planned on
tricking Kandra at all it just happened
to work out like that
get some spotlight which is cool he too
becomes a voice of reason
saying that Kaito and the rest know of
the raid plans and they want to get rid
of the nine scabbards in the three
supernova captains he points out that no
matter what plan they devise luffy and
kid are gonna be up front doing their
thing so la wants to build their
personalities into the master plan while
the straw hats and kid make a great
diversion by moving straight ahead the
rest can split off and go around as
originally intended but that too will be
bait was playing three-dimensional chess
over here and I love it
la suggests that the scabbards go with
his submarine they won't enter the main
entrance of the island they'll go around
the sea and use laws matrix room ability
to send them to the secret passage a
great plan that would be difficult for
anyone else to account for but kena moon
insists on leading the troops long story
short I saw some [ __ ] up and tells us
all that we really need to know by
saying that our guys will strike title
with everything they got we have the
same character dynamics repeating
themselves that we've seen in the last
few chapters with ki naman talking big
about the plan being finalized as he
expected it to be the whole time then
general reaffirming how much of a great
leader he is and rise old being like
really ki naman then law notices that
the straw hats are completely gone Luffy
has no time for boring planning he has
gone straight ahead they see an
explosion in the mist and here Luffy
then Joe panik's saying how he didn't
mention the Guardians at the port
there's a small fortress where there
should be soldier celebrating everyone
freaks out wondering if the soldiers got
the better of an unsuspecting Luffy and
his crew of course Luffy and the others
finish off the Guardians quick without
breaking a sweat
while hilariously enough OSAP Nami and
chopper just chillin the ship watching
they complement the others ooh Saab says
good work
chopper says great start hanami is like
not bad man you gotta love the na kama
dynamics while the others are worried
about them Zorro has already found the
alcohol he does in fact have alcohol
observation haki confirmed then the
other see that the straw hats were in
fact successful then Joe is shocked at
how skilled they are
he says the guardians were supposed to
be their first difficult task and the
straw has just torpedoed right
them showing how powerful they are at
this point the straw hats cheer and even
Luffy is about to have a drink in his
dope coat and I don't know why I always
have to mention how dope that coat is
but man what a dope coat however and
here comes the title Luffy says that
they will not party or drink now they'll
first deal with Kaito and then with big
mom in orochy I love how Yong ko big mom
is just like an afterthought here man
this is crazy AF Luffy proclaims that
they will win this war first against two
yong ko and friends and then they'll
throw the biggest bank whatever a
banquet that's sure to put the Yong chol
banquet that Kaito and big mom are
having to shame Luffy doesn't just want
to beat that infighting he wants to beat
them in partying too I don't know if
smiley is officially a word but I love
how smiley Luffy is and how he seems to
be not scared at all by these Yong chol
who have a combined bounty of about nine
billion berries and keep in mind that
isn't even counting the bounties of
their cruise crew members like Queen and
category also have bounties over a
billion apiece Zorro is smiling too but
his smile is also like yo we're doing
something crazy here but Luffy is just
unfazed even after what happened during
the last fight with Kaito man I don't
know what Oda is planning but I'm hella
excited to see how our boys are gonna
pull it off now we can look forward to
an amazing banquet afterwards and you
can bet after a war with two yong ko if
they survive that's gonna be the most
rewarding thing ever I think even for us
those celebratory chapters are gonna be
so satisfactory after the crazy fight to
come kid who has no chill tell Sophie
for the millionth time that he's the one
who's going to be taking kylos head and
we even get to see killer reaffirming it
too I love seeing killer here and I'm
glad that even though he's still
laughing uncontrollably he's on the
right side again you got a love kid's
personality he says that he'll make
idols had a kid the world's strongest
creatures head into an ice figurine for
his ship talk about the balls on this
dude simply amazing killer continues to
laugh uncontrollably and an irritated
and competitive Luffy tells djembe to
beat them in a naval race jimbe is happy
to get on board
we have some light heartedness before we
get into the Destin fight I almost feel
like this joy we've been experiencing
recently with the reunion and all is
gonna be starkly contrasted to the
horrors of this war I think it will be
an epic battle but we're also gonna get
some big debts here then we jump to the
yonk Oh finally to see what they're
doing
Orochi and the beast pirates including
Queen are having a good time celebrating
big mom is off screen but she's
somewhere close and there's some red
bean soup being prepared for her then we
get some huge news from Kaido he's
looking for his son who as far as you
can tell hasn't even peeked his head out
at the banquet Qaida wants him searched
for so we're probably gonna find out who
it is
soon wow kaido's fricken son imagines
the potential power of this dude if it's
anything like white beard and Edward we
will this guy should be a beast pun
intended as if that wasn't enough epic
news to leave us with we learned that
the flying six headliners are here and
the big mom is changing into a kimono
it's funny how even though these guys
are so monstrously powerful they're so
human at the same time that big mom even
wants to wear a kimono in wha No
in classic Oda hai building anticipation
we just see the feet of the six
headliners we know that there's
undercover agent Drake page one and four
others including a woman it seems this
is huge
we know that page 1 and Drake are strong
and there are four more on that level
then there are the all-stars like Jack
Queen and King who should be the
strongest of the three oh man
things are at a boiling point right now
we've been getting some easy double use
as we're rearing up for the stronger
battles but those ezw shouldn't last
long now and we're probably gonna be
getting some more big reveals there's
been theories for a while that Kaito
might be a dragon with an ancient human
kind of fruit something like a caveman
some fans suggest that this is why he's
called the strongest creature rather
than the strongest human we also saw a
silhouette of a dragon in the last few
pages that could be anyone in this beast
filled Kingdom but if we find out that
Kaito son is a dragon too that could
lend some credence to the old
title is a dragon theory my personal
favorite theory though is still that
kind o is a duck smash the like button
if you agree anyways whatever happens
I'm excited to learn more about the Sun
to see the rest of the flying six and to
see the fight to blow up to epic
proportions real soon the 100 arc has
been a good but long one and I think
it's been long because it was leading up
to one of the most epic battles yet if
not the most epic and I know it's gonna
be very very hard to top the battle at
marine Ford but a man can hope as always
let me know what you thought about this
chapter on what you think is going to
happen next chapter in the comments if
you enjoyed the review and want to keep
them coming
show one piece some love by smashing
that like button and sharing this video
can one piece get 4000 likes let us find
out if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and this is critical ring that
notification valve because you will miss
future one piece videos if you don't
remember to follow the anime opera audio
podcasts to get early access to reviews
like this one links in the description
lastly the YouTube ad rates have
significantly dropped recently so the
help and support we're getting from our
anime up or patrons is now more
important than ever a very special thank
you goes out to our patrons over on
patreon who help us survive YouTube
issues and who helped make videos like
this one possible first and foremost I
want to thank the legend acknowledged by
Lord Twigg of senpai sama himself baby
ray and the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans Stephan and
Radha a lowland autumn the world
stealers the school bus Tyson II know a
quiet respect and potata
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson King zelgius Anatole
Kazansky angel Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan
Kapoor cricket XP Ted no Ted Salter Joel
Stanton very gucci alicia actor animal
69 jessica calif on honoka me and water
and / otaku JCCC waka and the coach
thank you all so so much if you enjoy
our work you can always support more
by going over to patreon.com slash anime
uproar and becoming a patron today for
as little as $1 if you do so you'll gear
name feature in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course dank memes so
check out P channel calm and we have
four linked in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
YouTube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]